okay why don't we go ahead and get
started welcome everyone to our Thursday
conference and before I do that I just
want to put in a plug for our event on
May 18th but where dr. Kevin Johnson is
coming to show his documentary film on
health information exchange and there'll
be some discussion after that our today
as you know and you've heard me say
occasionally we devote these conferences
to specific types of events so today is
one of our clinical informatics Grand
Rounds that comes out of our clinical
informatics fellowship which is one of
the two fellowships we had and actually
the rest of you would probably be happy
to know that for the last couple months
particularly the last few weeks
Catherine and Andrea and Shannon and
Karen and myself have been working hard
on the competitive renewal for the NLM
training grant are other fellowship and
it went in and it's full Gloria 423 PDF
pages hopefully no one will print it but
anyways we we feel like we did a good
job and we did everything we could to
achieve competitive renewal which will
find out about the summer in the fall
anyway so our speaker today is one of
our first two fellows in the clinical
informatics fellowship dr. Jim Morrison
who most of you know from around the
department Jim hails from the state of
Michigan and did most of his education
or actually all of his education they're
starting with bachelor's degrees in
computer science and computer
engineering at University of Michigan
going to medical school at Wayne State
and then completing a diagnostic
radiology residency at Henry Ford
Hospital where he was also chief
resident eventually ended up at ohsu
interventional radiology at the daughter
Institute and then almost by accident
kind of found out about our new
fellowship and everything worked out
just fine and he and inhale Kim have
been our first two fellows and three new
fellows will be joining us on July first
in that fellowship anyway so Jim is
going to report on quality improvement
project that he does that the fellows
the clinical informatics fellows do as
part of their projects and so as part of
their fellowship so I will turn it over
to him oh and for those who are watching
out in cyberspace if you want to send a
question about the conference a to gym
hashtag de maiz comp all right thanks
Bill so I'm going to talk about a
quality improvement project that I've
been working on pretty much since i
started fellowship last July I call it
automating EHR data collection and
extraction for a multi-purpose data
registry I don't have any financial
disclosures and Vishnu asked me to put
some learning objectives together about
a half an hour ago so I'm spur of the
moment I said understand the need for
clinical data harvesting and then disk
strategies release the strategies that
I've tried to use for harvesting
clinical data including I'm going to
talk about my current solution so a
little bit of background some contexts
just introduce you to interventional
radiology if you're not familiar with it
why we're different why we need data the
data that we create and how are we
trying to harness it so as bill
mentioned I made my way to ohsu as an
interventional radiology fellow and just
some background since we're all owe a
chess you employees Charles daughter was
the department head of intervention of
radiology and he's actually the he was
the first person to do an angioplasty
and so he's the father of interventional
radiology and if you've ever driven past
the VA you'll see this little weird
looking house structure that says
daughter institute that's our research
lab so
if you've ever been curious about that
that's that's why that's why it's there
so this is the birthplace and if you go
to the 11th floor of the hospital is a
big plaque that commemorates dr.
daughter and his accomplishments so what
do we do basically we use imaging
technologies to do minimally invasive
surgery so we use catheters and wires
through blood vessels in the body to do
things like what I have pictured here so
the image on the left is actually an
angiogram and this is in a Orta and this
patient has developed a hole in between
is a Orta and is esophagus so these are
blood vessels and this one in the middle
that's actually is esophagus so that's a
bad situation and it right here we have
a stent that's in place before it's been
deployed and then the image on the right
is actually a CT scan after it was
deployed and you can see the stents
outlining the aorta and it's covered the
hole and stop the bleeding so that's
just kind of an idea of one of the types
of procedures that we do to set up my
talk I picked a couple of cases
additional types of things that we do
probably two of the most frequent
procedures that we do in interventional
radiology the first one is placement of
central venous catheters so case 1 i'd
say is a patient who came to us he got a
tunnel dialysis catheter and after
placement after he's had at about 10
days it's the placement areas red it's
warm he's got a fever he's not feeling
well and it turns out this line is
infected and that's a big deal any time
an implant then the body gets infected
as a big deal and it's a big deal across
the nation in fact catheter associate
associated bloodstream infections has
been kind of one of the main things that
has been identified for quality
improvement trying to reduce the the
rate of infection of catheters in the
body and case number two is something
that also happens quite a lot a patient
has an operation in this case something
like appendicitis he gets an
appendectomy and a couple days after his
surgery he develops an abscess and the
traditional way of taking care of this
be to take them back to surgery open it
up try and get all the pus and infected
fluid out of there and what we can do in
interventional radiology is just stick a
needle in a catheter in place don't have
to take the patient to the operating
room that's all done image-guided so we
can see what we're doing and it's done
very safely and it's usually a quick and
easy procedure in comparison to a big
surgery so we'll come back to those in
just a little bit so what kind of data
do we create basically there's two kinds
of data one at the top here is in the
EMR we create clinic notes we see
patients in the clinic before and after
surgery and we create procedure notes
any time they have a procedure and then
a little bit different after each
procedure there's a dictation that is
created and that goes into the packs
which is the picture archive and
communication system so it's actually
separate from the the EMR it's a
separate source it's a separate database
a separate source of data so those are
the two main types of data that we make
how do we use that data well we use it
for case logs so everybody every fellow
that goes through an interventional
radiology program makes a case log and
you need it for graduation we use the
data to create patient or disease based
registries and as silly as it is most of
our registries are just Excel
spreadsheets which are kind of hand
curated by nurses or physicians in the
department and then we also use the data
for research and this is a picture of an
Access database because in our
department we have a couple of access
databases which are used to collect data
about patients and use that to help us
do research on outcomes so kind of the
question that led to this quality
improvement project is how can we build
a system that satisfies all our needs
research education operational while
minimizing the impact of workflow and
harnessing kind of existing technologies
so this is my experience in
was kind of three Island error systems
that I went through one was a
proprietary system I've made myself one
is an open source solution that I
considered but never actually
implemented and then the final one is
going to be the solution that I'm using
now so for data collection one you can
do it by hand and we already do this the
fellows like I said we already
transcribe each case that we do into a
case log in order to graduate from a
fellowship you have to have logged at
least 800 cases and so my first idea was
can I take this just make it electronic
make an electronic case log and in
instead of writing it down people would
log this into like a website and that
was pretty ambitious especially I was
trying to do this at the same time I was
doing my interventional fellowship and
it was it was a bit too time-consuming
to actually make a workable system so
instead I created something I called the
venous access tracking system I just
selected one type of procedure in this
case it was that central line placement
and I built a system the diagram kind of
schematic of the system is on the right
it's an oj s system with the MongoDB
database and it has a web front-end
where we can log the catheters that are
placed placed in the department and then
we actually at the time we had a medical
assistant who was using the system to go
back and and log outcomes so she would
go back in a patient's record after
placement and say whether the catheter
was infected or if there were any issues
with it and the screenshots the left
their kind of hard to see but it's
basically just grange screenshots of the
application and use so you can put you
can log each catheter that's placed you
can browse through all the catheters
that have been placed it would
automatically prompt after a certain
time period for catheters that needed to
be followed up on and then down on the
lower right is kind of the head on
demand adalat analytics so you could see
which types of catheters have been
placed and how frequently and how
frequent was the rate of infection and
then the medical assistant left so then
we kind of lost our person on the ground
that was using the system so that was
that was the kind of proprietary system
the prot the biggest problem with that
is it's it's adding additional workflow
in that or or it's replacing a hand
workflow with an electronic workflow
which wasn't wasn't great because it's
it wasn't a great workflow to begin with
so I was trying to come up with a better
way to do this something that would be
more automatic and one thing that is
created for every case that's performed
as a dictation and it has a ton of
information in it what you see listed
here and after every case and attending
will dictate this that's what's used for
billing and coding and so it seemed like
a very rich source of information and I
have a colleague at another institution
that had built a radiology reporting
database in this schematic here so
basically what we have is as I mentioned
before there's the packs which is our
radiology database there's the EHR and
then anytime a report is created in
dictation software there's communication
that happens that report gets sent to
the EHR gets sent to the PAC system and
it does that using an hl7 feet so how
flevoland is a is a secure communication
standard for passing things like reports
between these systems and there's a
piece of software free software open
source software called mirth connect
that can sit on an hl7 network and it
can identify particular types of
information specifically it can tell you
this is a radiology report and so using
a technology like that you could pluck
the radiology reports off the network
put them into your own database index
some search them use natural language
processing to try and get information
out of the out of the text and so that
was my idea I knew that had worked at
another institution the Radiological
Society of North America actually has
standardized reports so in order to try
and get information out best to use a
standardized template from of this is
it's hard to get attendings to change
habits it's also there's a lot of
overhead building that system I have to
get approval from the hospital at the
find a place for to live on the network
and so basically there was just too much
overhead with this particular solution
and as much as I'd still like to build a
radiology reporting database because I
think it's a rich source of information
I haven't gotten there yet so actually I
was presenting that venous access
tracking database at the Society for
imaging informatics and medicine meeting
and a guy came up to me after the
meeting and he said you know you can do
this in epic and I said I didn't know
that and so he explained to me how this
use from the University of Texas
Southwestern and he explained to me how
they were doing it so do it during do it
using the EMR and as it turns out you
know the workflow is already in place
after every procedure that we do we
create a post procedure note that's the
that's kind of the drop in template that
we use and anywhere there's three dots
you can tab through those fields in epic
so the fellows place a note after every
procedure it's a standardized template
and so what I wanted to do is take that
template and be able to grab that data
from each one of those procedure reports
and then use that as my database so epic
also provides something called smart
data elements so they're customizable
data elements they can be built into a
template just like I showed you you can
grab text you can do specified
categories numbers dates and times it's
searchable you can either do the search
through epics production system which
works off a translational database and
then or you can pull that information
out from the relational database epic
clarity if you're familiar with that and
in fact there's just one big table and
clarity which is all the smart data
so it makes it easy to get that
information back out of the system so I
built a smart form like I said I started
working on this back in July and I
finally have my smart form bill and if
you notice it's very similar to the
procedure note that we are already using
instead of just having kind of fields to
tab through their set fields and buttons
that you can click and in standardized
fields and each one of these fields
actually becomes a capture bold Atta
element which is automatically
integrated with our EHR and when a
procedure is performed you fill this all
out and in the end it gives you a note
that looks pretty much the same as it
did before so reporting I haven't gotten
there yet my smart form just went live
yesterday so the first time I use it
it's working but the information is
actually being saved and stored in epic
but reporting is coming soon so two
types of reporting are possible as I
mentioned there's the production version
of epic it's a uses this transactional
database that's very quick it's actually
the same type of database that's used
it's not underpinning of vista at the
system that's used by the VA it's good
for operational reports it's good for
quick reporting uses a tool called
reporting workbench so you can grab
information very quickly from the last
week or last month it's a good solution
for a case log if you want to just go
back and quickly see what what have I
done in the last week and there's also
reporting that can be done from the data
warehouse so this is the kind of
reporting that is done through the
what's done in various areas of the
institution here but I rotate it with
the reporting group at itg and most of
the reporting that day they do actually
comes out of our data warehouse which is
a little bit different it's a relational
database every night they take all the
information that has been added to epic
and the translational data transactional
database and they move it over to
clarity which is this huge relational
databases has thousand
the tables in it but it's really good
for long-term reporting because all the
other information is stored and as I
mentioned there's just a huge table of
all these smart data elements you can
grab all the information that you want
and so it's really good for kind of
research or educational reports if you
want to just look at patients that had a
particular type of procedure over you
know the last ten years you could do
that this is example the reporting
workbench report that just shows all the
it's just I just ran this really quick
it shows all the all those types of
notes the post procedure notes that I
personally put in the system and then
this is an example of like a Cognos
clarity reporting or a report built
around clarity that looks at turnaround
times for surgical cases so why is this
important well the idea is that by
putting the post procedure by putting
these data these structured data
elements in with the post procedure note
it kind of lays the infrastructure for
future quality improvement efforts so
when somebody has a procedure it's it's
known it's now kind of it's in the
system at this date and time this
happened anything that happens in the
future it's really easy to go back and
reference that so you can look at things
that aren't in the post procedure note
like labs or other imaging studies that
were done and you can relate it back to
that that point that date and time when
that procedure happened in addition what
I'd like to do in the future is create
more of these smart forms with
structured data elements that would tie
back things like outcomes for procedures
so we follow up with patients after they
have a surgery and you know 6 3 months 6
months 1 year afterwards if you just
have a more structured data that you can
that you can associate with the original
procedure then you can really you can
really get some powerful information
back so it also gives us a better map of
activities in the department for
resource planning and allocation is
ridiculous as it seems we actually have
no way to know what we did in the last
month
how many procedures we performed what
kind of procedures they work so this is
this is part of the solution to
answering that is actually being able to
say well we're doing you know X number
of these procedures versus Y number
these procedures and we don't need to
keep you know certain types of catheters
and wires in stock because we just don't
use it that often and then last but not
least takes advantage of work already /
already being performed so like I said
this is after every procedure that
happens a fellow will put this note in
the computer and then at some other
point in time you have to go and
document it in his case report and then
if he's doing a research project you
might have to go back and do chart
review and find you know the same
information so this actually kind of
consolidates that reduces some of that
redundancy instead of having to you know
man manually write all these things down
you can just run a report and get his
entire case log for the year which is a
past fellow would would have been very
nice so back to the cases so case one
was that central central catheter
placement and as I mentioned central
line-associated bloodstream infections
major source of healthcare related
infections you know I built that venous
access tracking database to try and help
us know how often you know what is our
rate of infection was our outcomes for
patients with these so it's you know
this system will replace that it
provides a baseline for kind of
longitudinal tracking and new gatha ters
are invented catheters that are supposed
to prevent infections so knowing which
catheters are placed in which patients
we can actually look at outcomes and see
if new new types of devices are safer
have a lower infection rate case to that
was the abscess drained so with this
type of type of a system we have an
ability to identify and summarize the
procedures performed as I mentioned we
really didn't have a way to track what
types of procedures are performed if
you're an outpatient you're coming in
your name is on the schedule associated
with it with a procedure but that's
about half the work that we do the other
half of it is is in patients and most of
these post surgical patients
in patients their unscheduled so they
don't actually show up anywhere else in
epic we get a phone call that says hey
this patients not doing well they got a
CT last night there's an abscess we put
a drain in him so he comes to our
department has a procedure done and then
disappears so this is actually a way to
see how many of these procedures were
doing and again all that same data with
outcomes and tracking of the equipment
used and all those types of things same
same things apply this is also something
that has never been shown to actually be
a better solution than taking patients
back to the or now it may make sense
that if you're avoid surgery you know
it's you don't have to put the patient
under general anesthesia the equipment
used is cheaper the time spent and the
people involved is less impact on the
hospital and there's equal if not better
outcomes for the patient then this is a
better solution but nobody's actually
ever done the study that shows that
using percutaneous catheter drainage is
actually better than taking a patient of
the or and patients still get taken back
to the or for for surgical drainage so
if we could enroll other people in this
other institutions to get enough data to
show that you know comparative
effectiveness this is equal or better
than kind of the gold standard then that
would be pretty powerful so kind of
nationally the Society for
interventional radiology has a desire to
do this type of data gathering and
analysis there is a structured reporting
initiative which works off of a system
very similar to what I mentioned with
the reporting database so they have
structured template reports that for
about five different procedures that
they're trying to get people to start
using those reports and they built a
kind of automated system to send this to
some centralized server and there's
about five institutions that have signed
on the problem is they're structured
dump loaded reports are five pages long
and getting people to switch from like a
single page report to a five page report
it doesn't fit with their normal
workflow is very very difficult to do
and then the
medical device Abedini ology network is
another national effort for anything
implanted in the body and so we do
stunts placements we do you know
catheter placements we replace you know
foreign objects in people and this this
epidemiology network is specifically
geared towards trying to investigate the
long-term outcomes of any of these
implants so we need registries like this
to know what was placed in who and when
and how did they do long-term so what
comes next well as I mentioned now I
have to start working on the reporting
because I'm actually collecting the data
standardization of procedural data
elements so you know we're an epic
institution this was built using epic
tools the nice thing is if you're the
first person on the scene you get to
define your smart data elements and you
can actually suggest them to epic and
they'll make it part of the foundation
or like kind of the baseline
installation and push it out to all the
other institutions out there so if I can
get it working here and show that it's
working and get it on get epic to buy
into it then I can make it very easy to
actually expand this to other
institutions out there and that's part
three is getting other people involved
and and interested and then perhaps
making this a national effort that's it
that was pretty quick any questions yeah
you you kind of come across the
conundrum that we always face in
informatics with clinicians and trying
to collect structured data how are you
handling data that that you want to kind
of be able to perform reliable measures
on but the clinicians aren't willing or
able to you know choose the check boxes
and things like that that they want
because you know I think one thing we've
learned over the last several years is
that you know physicians don't like to
do that even though that would give us
the kind of store
sure data that we could do all kinds of
interesting things with how of you can I
handled that engine well so one thing
that makes it easier is that we're a
small department and right now we're you
know we're the only people using that
smart forum and specifically the people
using the smart form of the fellows and
so it's a lot easier for you know the
chairman of the department to tell the
fellows you need to use this than it is
to say it's all the attendings hey you
know change change what you're used to
doing and and and use this structured
report actually that's exactly why the
structure reporting initiative by the s
IRS had such trouble getting off the
ground not to mention the fact that
different institutions use different
types of dictation software that can
actually do the the structure reporting
that that they need to be done so part
of it is just you know we can actually
enforce this on top of the fellows the
other part of it is that you know I've
really tried hard to make this smart
form that we're using as close to the
workflow that we were doing before and
at the same time providing benefit to
the fellows and that we can
automatically gather all your case
logging data you don't have to do this
you know extra stuff by hand at the end
of a long day when you're you know not
interested in writing down every case
that you've done you know you just run
the report and there it is ranked
running
you
that's I mean that's a good question the
certainly we have to show for fellowship
we have to show how many cases we did
but there's there's actually no
requirements on what the cases work so
doing a complex aortic reconstruction is
counted the same as a thick line so not
yet is the answer to kind of the moc
requirements but you know one could
imagine in the future that having this
data would be you know much more
desirable than having to go back and try
and recreate it
yes yeah yeah like I said it's easier
because you can force trainees to comply
with with a you know the data capture
method but I've tried to make it as easy
as possible as it expands to things like
outcomes over the long term than
building out additional smart forms to
try and capture clinical data that will
rely more on the attendings and so I
have supported my chairman which makes
it a lot easier it's it's almost equal
because it was a lot of typing before
and tabbing through each one of those
fields and so it's it's every bit as
easy to click a button where I've
noticed that it's there's a little bit
more overhead is just I actually have so
each one of those procedures you can
click on the click on the procedure and
that captures what procedure was
performed and then it drops down a
section called procedure details so
that's information that wasn't captured
in any way shape or form before so there
is a little bit extra work that needs to
be done but it's it's just button clicks
so okay in medicine a lot of people are
moving towards using drag and software
2424 dictations to improve our to
decrease the time that we spend with
documentation is this something that
would interface with dragon at all you
know I don't I have never worked with
the implement with the connection of
dragon with epic but certainly radiology
has been using dragon for years we have
like one of the most arcane systems here
called talk tech which is like dragon
one point oh that's actually one of the
problems though with with trying to get
data that way is people like to dictate
the way they like to dictate and while
some of the new if you've ever seen
power scrub 360 which is kind of a
corollary to dragon it actually has
click fields that are similar to what
you can get in the structured reporting
element or structured data elements so
there is some ability to do that but i
think the dictation actually yields
itself more to i'm going to do my own
thing NLP would be the solution to that
but i have yet to see an NLP system that
that can actually faithfully get all the
data out
it would be really nice to be able to do
that or just log the times when people
are you know when is the patient in the
room when was the time outperformed one
is the physician in the room I haven't
gotten there yet we made the decision as
a department I didn't but when optime
came online the decision was made that
you know the workflow for off time was
not not didn't fit very well with
interventional radiology which is kind
of too bad now because you collect a lot
of great information just like what
you're talking about and so some of some
of those some of those things are
actually we're moving to a new rissa
radiology information system it's epic
risk called radiant that actually
includes some of some of those some data
points so hopefully these still working
in conjunction with one another because
radiant doesn't have anything that would
replace this
a few things well a case example first
so I think a great case for kind of
expansion of this in the future would be
something like uterine artery
embolization so there's a procedure that
we do there's a there's a benign tumor
called a uterine fibroid and the
procedure that we do basically shuts off
the blood supply to the tumor and we
want to see that over time it gets
smaller it shrinks so the post procedure
note would again act as that kind of
like time stamp that says the procedure
happened on this date and this time with
you know this kind of material I like a
smart form that could be dropped into
kind of the follow-up clinic notes
because we know that and actually the SR
has published quality initiatives that
say at six months you should see that
the tumor has shrunk by fifty percent on
volume and that should be pretty easy to
do because I mean that's just that's a
couple button clicks it's something that
I can guarantee you the the attendings
re looking at the post-operative imaging
and dictating in the report the
incentive is just like you know here we
can actually give you valid information
back if you take this extra step and I
think the attendings that would most
likely be using that they're young
enough to understand that don't don't
mean to insult the older attendings but
they're young enough to understand that
you know these things are important and
in the future for things like
maintenance of certification or you know
justifying that the procedures we're
doing are actually effective and working
we're going to need that kind of data to
support ourselves
all right thank you very much
you